[Music]
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator tv
and broadcast on thursday 31st of march
i'm katie balls the spectator's deputy
political editor and i'll be your host
this week
on this week's show
joe biden said that putin cannot remain
in power
but then the white has backtracked
is the american president really
advocating for regime change in moscow
matt purple who writes this week's cover
piece will be on the show freddie gray
it comes as russian and ukrainian
delegations are negotiating a peace deal
or at least trying to what's the latest
and will putin stick to any agreement
i'll be joined by former state
department official michael kimage
the metropolitan police have issued 20
fines into their investigations into
parties in downing street
but has the sting been taken out of the
row
james forsyth and israel hardwood will
be on the show to discuss and give us an
update on the mood amongst tory mps
richard florida writes in this week's
magazine that after two years cities are
back
he'll be on the show with the
spectator's business editor martin
vanderwear
and finally as energy prices saw lionel
shriver says she never turns a heating
on anyway lionel will join me to discuss
and offer some tips
before we get going a very special thank
you to canaccord genuity wealth
management who is sponsoring the week in
60 minutes canaccord are experienced
wealth planners and investment managers
who go on above and beyond to offer you
support and guidance just visit can do
wealth dot com to find out more
remember to subscribe to our youtube
channel too click the red subscribe
button at the bottom of this video and
tap the bell icon to make sure you never
miss an episode
joe biden this week said that vladimir
putin cannot remain in power prompting
speculation that the american president
was going to push for regime change in
moscow however the white house or at
least those working for joe biden have
other ideas and quickly suggested that
was not the case
in this week's cover piece matt purple
asked whether the american president
knows what he's doing
matt joins me now alongside freddie gray
the spectator's deputy editor and host
of the americano podcast
matt freddie thanks for joining matt in
your cover piece you say that bynon's
comments ultimately encapsulate his
whole approach can you tell us more
yeah i think that there is no biden
without gaffs right and i i don't even
think that's that controversial
statement to make i think he would
probably admit as much
i think that he said himself that i am a
gaff machine and you know fair credit
where it's due for admitting his flaws
and his weaknesses
but yeah it's it i think biden's
approach so far has actually been rather
shrewd it's been careful it's been
cautious it's been condemning of the
russians but also understanding that
this could get much worse you know
applying a little imagination uh
understanding the stakes could be
nuclear here
but then there's always the issue
there's always the peril that he's going
to come out and he's going to say
something that's going to completely
undermine that
and i actually don't think that the
remark that he made when he was in
poland was that
terrible i mean i've wondered myself
whether or not uh this is gonna end
without putin being removed from within
it's certainly a sensible thing to think
about
but
it's that old problem you know you
couple that with all the other gas he's
made even just over the past week it's
that old problem of whether or not there
can be a coherent policy from the biden
administration uh without him him taking
the the shotgun and aiming it at his own
foot
freddie did you manage to see the merits
of that comment
well i found it a little bit odd some of
the reactions to uh biden's various gaps
it wasn't just the regime change gas it
was the remark to the 82nd airborne
telling them that they when they go into
ukraine suggesting that the us would
deploy troops and it was also the
respond in kind about chemical weapons
which as matt says in his piece is
brilliant piece says uh you know
suggested the us might be willing to
unleash sarin gas all over eastern
europe i thought it was a bit odd in
some of the reactions um that people
said oh he just says what everybody
thinks and i and i don't think that's
right i mean i don't think the leader of
the free world the president of the
united states should just say whatever
he thinks i think that's for idiot
journalists like me
i think it's unhealthy to have
a gaff machine president
however you know it's he sort of gets
away with it because everybody assumes
that there's a competent machine behind
him
and again as matt suggests it does seem
at the moment as though the biden
machine is working quite well
matt do you agree what freddie says that
i mean ultimately in the in the cons of
having a gaff prone president the fact
that the white house had to quite
quickly seem to contradict the person
who's supposed to be in charge of the
white house and given this is pretty
high stakes we're in a war
yeah i think so and i think i i mean i
think all our last four presidents have
all been gaff prone to one extent or
another it's almost a qualification for
the job at this point
and but but they've been gaff-prone in
different ways and with biden i think
it's
there's a fair amount of clever thinking
that goes into it there's a fair amount
of preparation by his underlings to to
set a coherent policy that didn't get
undermined whereas with trump it was
just more chaotic you know kind of back
and forth
um with bush it was you know just these
awkward you know bush-isms that would
come out of his mouth
so but but i also take freddie's point
you know look diplomatic niceties are
very important
the world of diplomacy is a very
sensitive a very careful one
and words matter and they matter a lot i
mean these are the kinds of people at
the state department for example who
stressed about the the slightest little
adverb or the slightest article in the
smallest sentence it really is vital
that you get the language right
and i i'm sure that biden has caused a
lot of internal headaches now i don't
think it's been that big a deal so far
because when he said respond in kind i
think everybody understood that was just
biden going off the cuff and
misspeaking like he sometimes does i
don't think anybody thought that we were
going to be you know coding eastern
europe with gas anytime soon but i do
still think that the possibility exists
that he could say something far worse
and far more
undermining and and that that could
cause him to cause us some serious
problems down the road
now freddie if we look at bayern's
general approach on ukraine and matt
says in his piece that ultimately
actually it could be described as
strikingly sensible if we put the gaps
aside and focus on uh what america's
been doing working with allies do you
agree with that
i think i think america has been quite
sensible so far i think if you look
historically america's approach to
ukraine uh has not worked very well i
mean the fact that there's a war there
at the moment and america has had so
much involvement and put so much
investment into ukraine and yet it has
not been enough to
stop a russian invasion and to stop a
war suggests that america has failed but
that's not down to biden necessarily
although we do have to go back to 2014
where biden was hugely involved
in the uh effort to sort of establish
america's national interest in the
ukraine
um and to make it clear to putin that
that ukraine was not his turf uh i think
that policy has failed and biden should
take some blame for it
in recent weeks however um i think the
approach of the administration does seem
to have been pretty sensible there was
the the publicizing of intelligence
which people have different views about
but it seems to have wrong-footed putin
to a certain extent
but again wasn't enough to stop the
invasion there was also the mig handover
question with poland which matt touches
on in his piece where poland sort of
wanted to hand uh mig fighter jets to
ukraine through america
which would have seemed to be a fairly
major act of aggression on america's
part and biden stopped that i think he
saw what a dangerous escalation that
could be
so yes i think biden the administration
is
handling this crisis quite sensibly so
far
but the danger of course as we've
already said is that biden the man says
something very very dangerous and it's
worth noting going back to what matt
says that one of his campaign slogans in
2020 was words have consequences because
he was presenting himself as the
anti-trump but really he's a
continuation of trump in terms of just
gabbing off
and i want to talk about biden's
position more generally but just before
we do do that matt i wondered on that
point that freddie just touched on and
you were talking about how both donald
trump and joe biden are gaff-prone
politicians
is the fact that joe biden is more
you know relaxed about relying on the
rest of the administration lying relying
on that knowledge and then trump was for
example i recently had
donald trump's former russia advisor
fiona hill on my podcast room of balls
and she was effectively saying trying to
give donald trump advice from russia was
pretty much impossible so is the fact
you have a politician that yes may
make plenty of gas but will listen
meaning that he is in a different
position and he's able to
build ties and work with other countries
in a way perhaps trump wouldn't have
yeah i think he can and i think some of
that actually comes from biden himself
you know he is an internationalist he is
a multilateralist he believes in
assembling coalitions of nations and
then you know kind of stopping at the
water's edge making sure they don't go
too far go to war so i think some of
that is actually coming from the top and
again that that's a bit of credit to
biden in his case but you also have to
remember too that sometimes the
bureaucracy the underlings can go
further than the president even wants to
go and one of the reasons we've talked
about the
the disparity between 2014 and today one
of the reasons why the policy became so
pro-ukraine so pro-made in revolution
back in 2014
was that you had a bureaucrats like
victoria newland at the state department
who were running around kiev handing out
sandwiches to demonstrators making it
very clear that america supported the
what was ultimately the overthrowing of
the government there and maybe that was
the right position to take but clearly
russia interpreted that as a threat they
invaded crimea very quickly afterwards
um that was i think even less obama than
it was some of the the people who were
under him
and so because the
bureaucracy is so thick in america
sometimes it becomes autonomous and you
can end up that the commands don't
always get all the way down the chain so
it really just depends on on who's in
charge um and we saw the peril of that
before in this case i think it's more
i think there's fair a fair amount of
unity throughout the government it's
just a matter in fact we we learned that
the mig jets didn't go to ukraine
because
uh biden had been told by his advisors
there could be real difficulties and he
sided with them so there's that that
moment of harmony there
i think with biden it's more an issue of
the advisors have to rush in and clean
up his verbal flubs
and that could become a problem
now freddie there's been
i think a reasonable amount of praise of
biden so far in spectator tv but yet if
you look at his poll ratings in america
um they're not particularly positive in
fact they seem to be on the decline so
what do you think's behind that is
anything to do foreign affairs is it due
to inflation what's driving it first of
all casey can i congratulate you on
getting that seamless plug for women
with balls
thank you for answering your questions
exactly on biden's approval ratings yes
they are hitting
new lows
inflation is a real problem
this administration has struggled to
grapple with most crises i'd say the
ukraine crisis so far and again you've
got to stress so far has been the one
issue it's handled reasonably
competently
so i think uh biden is in deep trouble
uh in the midterms it still looks as
though he's going to get a shellacking
to use the obama term
and uh there is no clear democratic
leadership alternative kamala harris is
even less popular and i think everybody
knows what a disaster she is now
uh and there are no other good options
for the democrats at the moment viable
or realistic options that is so uh the
democrats are in big trouble joe biden's
presidency is still in big trouble if he
can have some sort of uh savior of the
free world moment it's possible he could
reinvent himself but then you have to
come back to what we're talking about
here which is his um silly mouth
and just briefly on it freddie it's
interesting this idea of perhaps a
ukraine banks because
when we're looking at the situation in
the uk
there's lots of figures around boris
johnson supporters of boris johnson who
think that ukraine is effectively
helping him with some of his domestic
troubles but again when you look at the
personal approval ratings it doesn't
feel yet though despite praise i think
domestically both for joe biden and
boris johnson that this is a changing
voters opinions of the politician
more generally and why do you think that
is
well it's fascinating isn't it that
vladimir putin sort of gave an amazing
gift or opportunity to the leaders that
hate him most or that have most publicly
opposed him on the world stage
by giving them an opportunity to elevate
themselves in public opinion by
condemning him
and yet
the polls suggest that the public isn't
quite as moved as perhaps
the westminster bubble the wonderful
better term is
and matt i wondered when you look at
bina's numbers it doesn't feel as though
they started to fall around the time of
afghanistan so do you think mishandling
or the fallout from that decision to
redraw from afghanistan which perhaps
looked as though it would be popular on
paper has impacted how um us voters view
joe biden
i think the the withdrawal from
afghanistan didn't help because it was
done sloppily but i think they're really
i'm a big skeptic of so-called foreign
policy presidents i think george w bush
learned this the hard way uh he ran so
hard on iraq and the war on terror and
by the time 2006 came around uh gas
prices were going up the economy was
dipping and that he paid the price right
at the midterm elections that year and
later on in 2008 after the recession
uh biden is trying now to take a foreign
policy crisis i think and use it to mask
the difficulties he's having
domestically so he's calling for example
the price of rising gasoline here in the
united states he's calling that the
putin price hike
uh but everybody knows that gas prices
have been going up for the better part
of a year now it's not credible like it
doesn't strike anybody as credible um
inflation is a very big deal the price
of food is going up the price of
household goods are going up even during
a time of economic recovery that can
really sap whatever
rise you might see in your paycheck so i
think
all of that ultimately is going to
supersede
ukraine because you know you can turn on
the news you can watch cnn you can watch
the horrific images that are being
beamed into our homes but ultimately
people feel it in their pocketbooks
first and
foreign policy can become a kind of i
hate to call it a luxury item but but it
can feel that way for voters right if
it's something they care about primarily
if their own needs are taken care of
and right now that that's not the case
here in the united states and i think
that's why biden's approval ratings are
still so low
and finally matt uh where does this
leave this much talked about pivot to
china in terms of u.s foreign policy you
just spoke about how voters obviously
have their priorities in terms of their
day-to-day lives it seems as though
biden clearly there's still issues in
afghanistan but also a lot of time now
on ukraine and russia
do you think that's going to have to
take a backseat
yeah i mean we've been trying to do this
pivot to asia since about 2009 it's
looked like one of those cartoon
characters who can't stop slipping over
banana peels and upending rakes into his
own face i mean first it was
libya distracted us then syria
distracted us then you know that the
trump administration it's just been a
whole
really difficult process to handle
and i i think that
the question now is less on america than
it is on china and how china is going to
handle this specifically and they've
verbally been at least somewhat
supportive of russia but there's clear
indications that they're not happy about
this and they are really the center of
gravity in the east right now not russia
so it will be i think curious to see
how they handle this um
i do my sense is that the russia
issue is still a more short to medium
term one whereas china is still going to
be the rising threat you know the real
matter that we have to deal with in the
21st century geopolitical matter uh but
we'll see i also don't think it's fair
to say for example that because russia
invaded ukraine that china is
automatically going to invade taiwan for
example they're very different
situations uh china is much more
cautious overall
so they're two different challenges i
think uh but but yeah it's that old
pivot to asia and it just keeps getting
you know gridlocked by reality i suppose
thank you matt thank you freddie
and if you want to listen to freddie's
americano podcast it's on all the usual
podcast platforms or at spectator dot co
dot uk forward slash americano
russia's invasion of ukraine has stalled
and negotiating teams from the two
countries are meeting in turkey trying
to hammer out a peace settlement
putin has also said that his forces will
scale down the military activity around
kiev during the negotiations
is the end of the war in sight or is
this all part of a larger ploy from the
russian leader i'm joined now by michael
kimmich an official in the u.s state
department from 2014 to 16 who worked on
the russia ukraine portfolio
michael thanks for joining us on
spectator tv now there's lots of talk of
peace talks this week between ukraine
and russia can we take putin seriously
i think we have to take putin seriously
because of course he's
in many ways the primary actor uh in
this drama so what happens militarily in
ukraine
uh on the russian side is entirely uh up
to putin so seriously we certainly have
to take him
but his position in terms of the war
itself and in terms of negotiations is
extremely unclear at the moment
on that i wonder could you run us
through what appear to be the opening
positions of both russia and ukraine
well the russian positions have shifted
somewhat
over time it began the war began with
maximalist efforts on the part of russia
to so-called
denazify ukraine
and to
demilitarize the country that sounded
like regime change or occupation of the
entire country obviously the war has
gone much too poorly for putin for that
to be
conceivable now so what russia is
pushing for is some version of
neutrality
uh and then it's again unclear what
putin wishes to do with the territory
that his soldiers have occupied i think
that's just an ongoing part of the
negotiations uh ukraine clearly wants to
put an end to the war for all kinds of
practical and humanitarian reasons and
it wants to preserve as much of its
independence and sovereignty as it can
in the negotiations so the positions are
not at all close together at the moment
and it's going to be i'm i'm afraid of
long process
i suppose this is a million dollar
question but where where do you think
perhaps a compromise or both sides could
find some type of deal that they could
agree to
i don't think that the difficulty is
going to be on this question of
neutrality or nato membership i think
there
there's an achievable compromise what
ukraine wants from not from russia but
from europe and the united states as a
security guarantee
that's a pretty big step for the us and
europe to take maybe that's a step that
could be taken that would certainly
allow ukraine to feel much more
self-confident
in these negotiations but that's far
from a from a done deal i think this
most difficult part of the negotiations
and that's why i suspect they're going
to drag on for quite a while has to do
with questions of territory russia's not
going to hand back crimea
it's going to want to occupy parts of
eastern ukraine that's a very bitter
pill for ukraine to swallow so i think
that that will be worked out not over
weeks but over months uh depending also
on how things continue to go on the
battlefield
and clearly the war is not going as
putin planned if you look at the fact
it's taken them so long so far there's
not been um
success in terms of taking territory as
was talked at the beginning in terms of
the russian side and but does peter
norton need something he can sell as a
win for there to be any agreement oh
certainly and and putin retains a number
of escalatory options he could be taking
a pause before a new offensive begins in
eastern ukraine he could be using more
air power in the future it's not at all
sure that putin is winding the war down
on the russian side so certainly he's
not gonna surrender or retreat
uh or leave without getting significant
concessions from
uh from ukraine it's far beyond optics
of needing to make a sort of
phase-saving move for the russian people
i think putin still believes he can get
quite a bit out of ukraine and that's
what he's going to try to do
and we've seen the ukrainians ultimately
believing that they are having success
in pushing back russian forces so were
presidents lengths to agree to a deal
which perhaps ceded some land that's not
currently in control of russia to russia
um as in before the war do you think he
could sell that to his people there's
some talk of for example the referendum
before anything is agreed
it's difficult for zelensky nobody quite
knows how well things are going for
ukraine certainly much better than most
expected
much worse than russia expected things
to go
militarily but we don't know how
exhausted ukrainian troops are we don't
know the extent of losses of material
and you know we don't quite know how
difficult things are uh on the ukrainian
side that's of course what zelinski does
know and that's probably what's pushing
him to negotiate but he has mobilized
the ukrainian population so successfully
in the course of the war that that is
now a bit of a diplomatic or political
problem for him that
people would want to march forward
toward victory i think zielinski doesn't
believe that full victory is possible so
he's going to have to negotiate with his
own population at the same time that he
negotiates with putin it's not an easy
job by any means
yes exactly and i think the rhetoric
looking for elections but also some some
western allies in terms of
what this needs to mean for ukraine we
have boris johnson saying putin must
fail
does suggest actually the stakes could
be raised to a point that makes it hard
for it to be something russia could sell
as a win what role do you think western
allies are going to play in terms of
bringing ukraine to an agreement
well i think western allies have done a
lot
uh already for
uh for ukraine so this is not a story of
failure i think it's the story of
gradual success you of course had the
enormous sanctions that have been levied
on russia and you have a very rapid
effort on the part of the uk the u.s
and a number of continental european
countries to assist the ukrainian
military that's been a big part of the
war
and has taken ukraine really quite far i
think beyond that
if i understand the position correctly
in washington and i think it's similar
in europe i think that the idea is just
to give zelinski as much encouragement
as possible she wants to continue with
the war if he feels that that's
necessary
that will be supported if zolensky needs
to come to the table make certain
concessions get a provisional piece with
putin that too will be supported so i
think it's really um not a hard and fast
position on the part of the
transatlantic alliance uh it's a
position of maximal support for zelinski
himself now you spoke uh earlier about
how the fact it's quite hard to read the
intentions of putin and what russia
wants to get out of these negotiations
well they're taking them seriously well
actually it's to buy them time in terms
of re-strategizing
and there are also reports this week of
poisoning at the peace talks in the form
of
abramovich and potentially having those
on the ukrainian side now there's lots
of theories going around as ever nothing
is quite verified but i wondered
if there has been a poisoning and that
has affected one even on the russian
side negotiating does that tell us
anything is that could that be a warning
from the kremlin
well if it's true i mean it's just a
sign of of real insanity
uh on the russian side to do something
like that in the midst of uh in the
midst of negotiations if it's true and
there have been a few qualifications
offered to that story in the last 48
hours
it would suggest that russia is
completely unserious about achieving a
diplomatic result that they're going to
continue on with the war they're going
to be pushing refugees
into eu and
nato member states
you know they're going to
exploit the crisis for whatever they've
been exploited for
and they may think that they're winning
on their side so you know if they're
that unserious about the negotiations
that's a very bad sign but i'm not quite
sure that that's the case i think there
might be incentives on the russian side
not just for a pause
but for an actual deal i just think it's
going to be
convoluted and difficult and uh and
quite a while before we reach that point
of a real settlement
and what do you think the incentives are
for the russians ultimately i mean we're
seeing or we're hearing reports and as
of everything there's different figures
going around but very high fatalities in
terms of soldiers
is one the fact that it was actually
gonna be very hard to take ukraine now
it seems let alone try to hold it so
russia and putin does need an exit door
no not quite sure putin is able to see
the war in these terms i think he still
may suffer from wishful thinking and
perhaps false information from his
staff but if he's able to see the war
clearly the fundamental problem on the
russian side is not just that the
russian military
is losing is that the war is
perfectly counterproductive for russia
the point of the war was to detach
ukraine
from its military relationship with
europe and the united states the
opposite is happening that relationship
is deepening and the point of the war
for putin was to demonstrate that
ukraine is a house of cards that it's a
fake
government it's a fake country it's a
fake state and you've seen the opposite
happening in recent weeks where
ukrainians have been fighting valiantly
for their country in the spirit of
national unity so if a war is perfectly
counterproductive
you would have to assume that the right
approach is to end the war
and to finish it but that of course for
a person like putin and for a country
like russia having made this investment
in the war is not going to be easy to do
not going to be easy psychologically but
it's it's a correct move policy wise so
the question is whether they can
they can sort of see the war in those
terms and act accordingly uh and will
take a while i suspect
now finally david cameron the former uk
prime minister and a diary for the
spectator recently where he recalled his
own dealings with vladimir putin and one
of the things that he
said he remembered most was how the
russian leader would ultimately take
part in bare-faced lying so say we get
to a point whether it's you know in a
few weeks in a few months perhaps in a
few years time where there is an
agreement how do we know that the
russians are going to stick to it
we don't um you could add to david
cameron's i think very persuasive uh
interpretation of putin's character just
the evidence that we have from the last
couple of months you know putin
repeatedly lied about the military
buildup that it was an exercise that he
was scaling back that he was not going
to invade
ukraine all of the diplomacy that putin
engaged in before february 24th when the
war began
uh was duplicitous it was a kind of
political theater uh meant to convince
the ukrainians that russia was not going
to invade so i think it's entirely
plausible perhaps even likely that if
russia would sign a peace deal or if
putin would sign a peace deal with
ukraine
that he could concoct a reason three
months later to reinvade the country so
that
is a crucial fact for ukraine zolensky
is not in any sense naive on that point
and that has to be factored in on the
side of those who support uh ukraine
it's not worth much uh a deal with
russia it might be worth something in
the short term it's a sort of
provisional stop-gap solution for
ukraine but a permanent solution or a
permanent peace deal can only be
achieved with a russian leader other
than putin
thank you michael
over the past few weeks in westminster
the main issue has been ukraine and the
uk response to this but now partygate is
back the metropolitan police have
announced they're issuing a first batch
of fines it's still unclear whether
boris johnson will receive one and what
exactly happens if he does
to find out i'm joined by james forsyth
and israel hardman to give us an update
on the situation in westminster
isabel this week partygate is back in
the news after weeks where the focus has
been very much on the situation in
ukraine can you bring us up to date on
the fines that have been issued and what
could follow
yes so earlier this week the
metropolitan police confirmed that 20
individuals have
are going to be fined as a result of the
lockdown parties but that their
investigation is still ongoing because
they have a huge amount of material to
get through which means that we have a
lot longer to go in terms of the
conclusion of this row and indeed uh the
sugray inquiry
that's being run from the cabinet office
into
these parties and into the culture and
the leadership that allowed them
to happen and so far we've had it
confirmed by boris johnson's spokesman
that he has not received a fine so far
um and there has been some debate uh
over whether number 10 and boris johnson
accept that laws were actually broken
which has left a lot of cabinet
ministers having to go round the houses
on what the metropolitan police have
been fining people for
if there wasn't law breaking going on
we've also had kyostama renewing his
calls for the prime minister to resign
because he says he's misled the house
over what happened in downing street
having previously said that all guidance
uh was followed
james why would it be in downing
street's interest to suggest that the
law hasn't been broken despite the met
police appearing to find that there has
been
i i think as i think as well said it is
slightly puzzling uh the only uh one
possible explanation is that there would
still be at the moment time for people
to contest uh these fines so you you
couldn't maybe that is the reason but
but it is very odd especially when the
justice sector dominate rob
had said that they had been
on his morning broadcast round but i
think you do see i thought it was very
telling that brandon lewis last night
went on the television to say that you
know boris johnson shouldn't resign even
if he was fined which i thought was a i
don't think we've heard that so directly
from a cabinet minister on the record
before
and it is the where tory mps on this
because it does feel as though some of
the heat has been taken out of partygate
and the focus has moved to ukraine
there's lots of tory mps saying there
are bigger things to focus on there's
been some team bonding this week do you
think that without defining boris
johnson is safe and perhaps even with a
fine
i think without a fine uh he's safe and
i think that was probably just about the
case before christmas uh when things
were particularly intense that uh there
were probably enough conservative mps
who in the end would have supported him
uh in a vote of of no confidence back
then as you say things have changed
quite a lot since then the focus has
shifted but the focus has shifted not
just on to ukraine where
uh president zielenski has made clear
that he thinks the uk is helping more
than the most other countries
but on to something that is is very
difficult for the government which is
the cost of living crisis
and uh accusations not just from the
opposition but from within the
conservative party and indeed
suggestions from the prime minister that
the government isn't yet doing enough
to help people with the rising uh cost
of living and so you may well get a
situation
where mps are very very upset about
how their constituents are struggling in
the coming months and then
there's further fines from the
metropolitan police and the conclusion
of the sugree investigation
where the prime minister may not be
fined but the sum total of everything
else that comes out of those inquiries
is is really damaging for the prime
minister and destabilizes him again
james
once again i think the may local
elections are being talked about as a
judgment on the prime minister's
leadership on boris johnson but isabel
has pointed out some of the other
big issues in politics and for example
cost of living that is nicely in dynasty
is the number one issue for voters well
above
concerns over parties so if there are
disappointing results in the local
elections do you think that daniel would
be able to say this is to do general
political problems ron anything
personally to do with boris johnson or
at least argue that
i think dining street is getting ready
to argue but you know look bad results
in london you know you've known for some
time that the capital is moving away
from the tories they'll say
um and i think you'll also see that that
kind of classic local elections
expectation management game where where
where
the tories will suggest that you know
holding one counselor anywhere in the
country would be it would be a
remarkably good result for a government
in midterm so i mean you can set aside
all that i think israel is right though
that what is going to make politics so
difficult over the next few months of
the government is that people's real
living standards will be going down and
that will make people
unhappy they will wonder why the
government isn't doing more to help them
or why the government isn't steering a
better course and i think this is going
to be very very politically difficult
for government especially
difficult for boris johnson who is
naturally a kind of good time politician
you know he is not he's
as we've seen he doesn't like delivering
bad news to people and there's going to
be an awful lot of bad news over the
next few months and i think one of the
other factors of this
is it does mean that the government is
likely to go long i think that an
election before 2024 is becoming
increasingly unlikely because the
government will want to give as much
time as possible for this inflation to
kind of pass through the system before
they go to the country
isabel james was talking about how cost
living is difficult for boris johnson
politically but richard scenic has not
had an easy few weeks and ultimately uh
does it help boris johnson the fact that
the
candidate the figure who is seen as the
bookie's favorite to succeed boris
johnson our favorite natori leadership
contest is actually seeing his star on
the win
well i suspect that uh the treasurer is
probably feeling the treasury team
around rishi sunak is probably feeling
rather less uh superior to boris johnson
than they were a few months ago and i
think now is the time for for rishi
sunak to show that he
can be a normal chancellor as well i
think he got rather used to being
a pandemic chancellor who could as you
know we've discussed before uh put out
graphics with him smiling into the
middle distance and saying we are you
know launching this massive furlough
scheme we are throwing money at this
he realized last week that uh actually
pictures of him beaming uh next to a car
that wasn't his that he was filling up
at a petrol station uh didn't land very
well and he needs to move to being the
the sort of more aloof colder more
austere
persona that most chancellors tend to
create for themselves because the job
involves telling people that they can't
have the money they want whether that's
government colleagues or whether that's
people whether that's households who are
finding their living standards and their
budgets being squeezed
and james when it comes to labour's
response on this uh ultimately kirsten
is now calling again for boris johnson
to resign
do you think that it's going to have
much impact or is there some of the
polls are suggesting they're probably
losing interest when it comes to party
game thinking that are bigger things to
be talking about
i think that kia starmer has waited a
long time and not used some of the
parliamentary devices he could have used
when boris johnson was in the most
trouble with his own side to to cause
boris johnson discomfort i thought it
was telling the prime minister's
questions yesterday that when this
subject used to come up at pmq's yes
there were some tory mps who offered
kind of noisy vocal support to boris
johnson but a lot of them shifted um
uncomfortably in their seats while as i
thought yesterday at pm uh sorry um
i won on wednesday at pmq's they were
much more kind of comfortable you know
there was much more comfort in kind of
cheering boris johnson on from the tory
benches which i think does suggest a
slight moon shift there
i think as you've wrestled in casey
there's there is a question about
whether the mood shift in the public is
as pronounced as the mood shift at
westminster on this on this question
but i think in some ways kierstarma
for tactical reasons chose not to kind
of ram home the advantage when boris
johnson was in the most discomfort on
this issue
and i think i think he is finding it now
harder to get it going again but some
people would argue and this is certainly
the concern of some uh of some in the
tory party that you know but that labour
feel that this has taken a dent out of
boris johnson
and therefore they are quite happy to
have a kind of wounded
so this is taking a dent out of boris
johnson and in some ways for labour that
is job done
thank you james thank you isabel
after a two-year hiatus is life finally
getting back to its pre-pandemic normal
richard florida a professor at the
university of toronto writes in this
week's magazine that cities are back and
are better than ever he joins the show
now alongside the spectator's business
editor martin vanderwear who bucked the
trend during lockdown and moved to the
city
richard i speak to you from london where
i have to say it's pretty hard to get a
seat on the tube at the moment
reservations in i think what you
describe as the good restaurants
take perhaps weeks in terms of booking
in advance
and it feels rather busy if you look at
the various figures including many
members of the spectator office standing
outside pubs in westminster
so are cities back
i i think so and i think some are coming
back you know i i haven't been to london
in a while i wish i was with you
actually it's one of my absolute
favorite cities
and in putting together my piece for the
magazine it was quite clear to me
looking at data on restaurant bookings
uh
sports attendance theater attendance all
of these things housing prices rents you
know london is back and london is a big
tough city you know i would say new york
is coming back and and coming back
pretty quickly
uh i've spent a lot of time in the
pandemic in miami miami is fully back uh
you know also people tell me tel aviv i
was just with some folks from israel tel
aviv is full on but then you know you go
to some cities like my hometown of
toronto
i was in seattle recently cities that
were hit hard in the first wave and
maybe they've been a little bit more
tentative
they're far less back and of course as i
mentioned in the piece
i mentioned this for london where
offices are coming back more quickly
but one of the things is that in the
united states if you look at our 10
biggest office markets even though you
know i talk about this everything city
is back except for the office people are
going to restaurants they're going to
theater they're going to sports all of
these things going to movies going to
nightlife but they're not going to the
office at least in the united states on
average it's about a third
that office occupancy of that is about a
third of what it was pre-pandemic
in some texas cities and if you had data
on miami they don't really collect it
would be about half but you know new
york and san francisco are still about
25 so i think one of the points that i
tried to make is everything city is back
say for one thing people go into the
office
martin you bucked the trend during
lockdown and moved from the countryside
to the city something you've spoken
about previously on spectator tv
um do you do you agree and what we just
heard in terms of the city being largely
back minus offices
yeah
uh and everyone i talked to who's a sort
of regular office dweller as it were
they tell me they're back kind of half
time in the office i was on a
uh a webinar this morning with a group
who precisely that and so that's the
picture and i
agree with richard i think london is is
back i've just walked across central
london to come here this evening i
walked past a large queue
outside i think it's called dishoom a
popular indian restaurant i mean like 5
30 in the afternoon there were 50 people
queuing to get in i sat outside in a
courtyard in covent garden a little
earlier this afternoon there are lots of
people around
it's lovely and i think
i richard
might comment on this
an advantage of old cities
european cities i was in paris also a
few days ago
look full of street life is not being
entirely built with a kind of downtown
business district and a grid system of
office blocks and so on that would be
very hard to revive i haven't been to
canary wharf lately which is the nearest
thing to north america in in
architectural terms that we have but i
imagine that might still be a bit
desolate but old london as it were with
its alleyways its narrow streets and so
on is is back and in some ways it's
better because there's a lot of life
on the street on you know pavement cafe
life that we really didn't have before
and it's nothing to do with covert i
think it's probably the fault of the
mayor sadiq khan but there's actually
quite a lot less
unnecessary vehicle traffic nowadays who
brings a private car into central london
no one does so actually there's less
traffic uh if you know where to walk so
i think yeah it's back and it's better
yeah
so i i think you're spot on
and in fact one of the things that got
cut from the piece because in a magazine
piece you only have limited words is the
fact that one of the key elements of
london's resiliency
isn't its central business district or
office district these mono cultures
where we expected people
you know i say they're the last vestige
of the industrial age these ideas that
you build these work only communities
office districts where people commute
nine to five and it's desolate at night
what what makes london a great city it's
a city of villages it's a city of
neighborhoods it's an older city it's
it's and and what i think is that's
you know i think i might have mentioned
this in the piece it might have gotten
cut you know jane jacobs writing in 1958
before she wrote the death and life of
great american cities which was
published in 1961 her first big essay
was called downtown is for people and
she was making the point that these
monolithic downtowns were outmoded then
and and i think if we've learned one
thing from the pandemic is that these
single-use monolithic work-only
downtowns don't work for many people and
you said it so nicely
when you came in there was a queue in
front of this restaurant or this cafe or
this pub
i saw the same thing in new york city
this summer when it initially reopened
in july nobody was in the offices the
office towers were darkened
but there were cues around the block and
i think
you know i kind of part of this is my
fault
when i wrote my book rise at the
creative class i said cities were about
work live play
and i think the pandemic opened my eyes
is that cities are about a lot more than
work live play and if i had to revise my
own thinking i would say it's not work
live play
it's work live play and then the bigger
word like i would make all capitals
connect work live play connect
and i think what the pandemic is showing
us is that great cities are not simply
about containers for living or working
their containers their their mechanisms
are platforms for human connection and i
think that's what you're seeing in
london or new york or other great cities
now and it's quite an interesting thing
which is that the city i mean that
capital c
city of london
old financial district
um i don't know if you're familiar with
it richard but that has actually been
transitioning in this way now for at
least a decade that as the banks moved
on mass
down to canary war from the investment
houses moved up to to mayfair the city
turned into actually a bit of a
nightlife district and if you go down
there late in the evening you'll find
you know young clubbers you know
tottering along on their high heels and
there are there are burlesque clubs
there are all sorts of things you never
have found a generation ago so that i
think is a positive transition i wonder
i just wonder how canary wharf will will
ever transition to anything else or will
it have to be sort of torn down and
rebuilt in a more human scale and a more
mixed economy just on that martin before
we go to richard i just wanted you spoke
about how lots of companies right right
now do not have workers coming in five
days a week do you think that this is
something that is going to change
perhaps we're not quite out of the
pandemic yet and companies will return
to five days a week or do you think this
is a permanent shift to flexible working
for the major companies in the city
uh in some cases it may be in some cases
employers big companies spotted the
opportunity to economize on office space
by saying forever now we're going to be
a kind of hot desking model where you
you you work from home at least one day
a week and so on and they'll they'll cut
some costs by doing that um
most
most business people i know recognize
that there is there are these sort of
advantages of human chemistry of
bringing people back in most young
people i know who live quite a way out
are pretty sick of working from their
their bedrooms and so on so i think
it'll gradually it'll gradually mostly
come back but some businesses will keep
it as a model with a one or two days a
week out of the office as part of the
part of the deal as it were
but um what i'm guessing is i'm you know
i'm guessing this is that
young people particularly who are still
largely working from home love the
opportunity to come up into town in the
evening and have human contact and queue
outside you know dishoom the curry house
and so on uh so that the nightlife isn't
suffering that much from the working
from home um trend
yeah i think the jury is still out on
how much people will work from home
people are social animals and martin you
mentioned young people young people who
are crammed and jammed into
shared apartments
need need conviviality they need
connection they need socializing they
want to meet people they want to go on
dates
so i think right now we're just coming
out of the pandemic and the survey data
we have is just i think pessimistic
people are scared they're not ready to
go back to the office they're scared
they're kind of feeling their way
they're going to a restaurant they're
going to a nightlife
so i think give it spring and summer and
the warm weather you know absent another
wave the second thing
and that you said quite aptly is there
has been an ongoing shift in what we
call our central business districts you
see this in the financial district in
new york city which was rebuilt after
the tragic attacks of 911
they have been adding residences they've
been adding condominiums they've been
adding hotels they've been adding
restaurants they've been adding
nightlife and i think what the pandemic
has done it's accelerated this mixing
and blurring you know we used to have
distinct places to live
we had distinct places to work this is
the legacy of the industrial revolution
and i think now with this new way of
living and working in technology that's
blurring and i think you know yeah it
may be that places like canary wharf
have to be rebuilt but the
i guess the main point is that london
has survived far worse than this i mean
you don't have to be a rocket scientist
and you know my dad served in world war
ii he was stationed in london he
he stormed the beaches at normandy he
told me this stuff you know london
survived the blitz with the london
london survived the great fire london
survived cholera
great cities have survived far worse
than this and and i think the one that i
would rivet people's attention on which
is current day which i think is far more
deep far deeper than this one is
deindustrialization
you know when de-industrialization
started in the 60s and 70s people said
places like london or new york or boston
could never survive when the factories
left town and the warehouses were
abandoned you know the cities would
collapse and of course london and new
york and we can go down the list
uh transform those industrial districts
transform those warehouse districts
rebuilt those factory loft centers into
art galleries and ultimately that's
where the tech companies want to be now
so
it's just silly to think that an event
like covet would would take london to
its knees london will adapt and change
and that's why we call cities
our greatest you know humankind's
greatest creation civilization's
greatest creation because they adapt and
change and that's what we're seeing now
well i was just going to add to that i
suppose that's all true
de-industrialization in london would be
most visible in docklands
the death of the docks as docks and
their recreation that's been going on
for 40 years now and largely very
successful
what i was going to say was
an after effect of covid generally is
that people have an urge for fresh air
that meant initially people leaving the
cities now you tell us the trend is they
may be coming back into the cities but
they still want the fresh air and i
think that's great because i suspect
what we'll get in the next wave of urban
development is more green space more
tree planting more appreciation of parks
more care for the small
neighborhood green spaces and i see that
i just
had that thought this morning because i
wandered down my street in covent garden
there's a new tree it's an
uh
ornamental pear tree blossoming and it's
just been planted
in the sidewalk and i then emailed the
head of our
residents association who
leads a fight to make sure they don't
completely privatize all the pavements
by putting cafes on every pavement and i
said if we've got to give way to more
cafes on pavements which on the whole i
like but not excessively couldn't we ask
for more trees and actually if we get a
whole avenue of trees it'll be ever more
lovely so i think there's a kind of
fresh air in the city thing is going to
happen in the next one one thing that's
surprising to me
you know the vaccines have been a
miracle like it's it's a miracle of
medicine
um and even these treatments these
antivirals have been quite miraculous
but
in many ways an equal if not more
important way to deal with not just
covet but all sorts of viral illnesses
is ventilation
you know and and it's not really talked
about if you look at previous pandemics
there have been changes in the built
environment you know open windows that
would open the invention of the modern
powder room on the first floor where you
took off your muddy boots and you washed
your hand and the usage of of modern
stainless steel and porcelain fixtures
and bathrooms you know these are all
legacies and pandemics no one has really
talked about the changes in the built
environment that we need and and i think
you're spot on it's it's ventilation
fortunately london has older buildings
and older homes where the windows open
they're not sealed hermetically but yeah
and and moving things and not just
leisure activity
moving things like parts of schooling
and office work
or work outside into the fresh air or
into ventilated environments that's a
big thing and i haven't seen enough i
mean it's a whole other essay but i
haven't seen enough conversation about
that
and just finally martin we're talking
about how office space there could be a
more permanent move though still to be
confirmed what do you think uh is
ultimately going to fill that if if we
do see you know fewer offers already
seeing some of that in terms of uh what
place in cities what what will be there
instead
well
there's a housing crisis right
um
there's a great shortage in
uh inner and outer london of the kind of
one studio one two bedroom flat for the
first time buyer for the young
professional the young
worker who has to commute into the
center of the city so the obvious and
logical development is a whole lot of
redundant or vacant office space gets
turned into small
living units of course
um
extending that it's nice to have more
kind of entrepreneur
hub spaces where people can go sit
designing apps and all that kind of
stuff you know uh um but i think
the first thing that should happen now
is a sort of review of just how much
office space is needed in each area and
if there's too much of it there should
be grant schemes there should be all
sorts of competitions for architects to
come up with creative and livable ways
of turning it into
small units for basically young people
first time buyers renters and so on that
would be a great transition and if it
happened the street life in those areas
would change accordingly you know with
the cafes restaurants shops and and
everything that people want
you know i talk about this in the piece
that one other thing london has been
really good at is inventing these third
places like cafes and bars and taverns
you know i mentioned lloyd's of london
and john you know
the london stock exchange coming out of
jonathan's coffee house in the late
1600s
but you know right now whether it's soho
works the the the co-working arm of the
soho house or second home for uncommon i
mean i named these all in drafts of the
piece i went and looked at work life you
have created these kind of bespoke
co-working i don't even know what the
right word for them it's collaborative
working co-creating spaces
they're in almost every neighborhood now
and i think that's where we go it's it's
not the office as a cubicle farm where
you plug in your laptop and sit there
from nine to five
it's these new kinds of flexible spaces
which blend hospitality and a club
atmosphere and conviviality
the other thing is you're doing a darn
good job of building you know a good
buddy of mine from toronto a young man
named ryan prince has a company called
uncle you know an uncle in london is
building these kind of smaller co-living
spaces and you have that's not the only
one there's quite a few of them so
i think this is a reinvention of a city
in a way i'm not sure the one thing i'm
not sure of
is how much office space we're going to
need to reconvert let me tell you i have
a good friend in toronto
who've been very much worried about this
and toronto suffered through probably
some of the greatest lockdowns it has a
very low space of office re-entry
and he told me the other day we're gonna
have to add a floor of office space and
i said why he said yes we have more
people working remotely but we hired so
many people during the pandemic if we
want to make some semblance of space
even if they're hot desking and hoteling
we need to add more space so many of
these firms in big cities like toronto
or london and new york
and the other thing of course which i
mentioned in the piece if you look at
who's really taking up space in london
it's not the finance insurance or real
estate firms it's so-called fire
it's big tech it's the amazons it's the
googles it's the big tech companies that
are that are taking increasing positions
in the london's in new york so
i'm not sure we we might end up net with
more office space although some of the
older you know more traditional cubicle
farm offices may have to be converted
but we we may end up at net net with
more office space in cities i don't i
don't think we can predict that yet
thank you richard thank you martin
and finally spectator columnist lionel
shriver writes this week that she's got
a simple solution to rising energy
prices not turning on the heating in the
first place to give her best tips lionel
joins the show now
thank you for joining us today on
spectator tv liner now there's lots in
the news about rising energy bills it's
only going to get worse but in your
column you discuss you've been ready for
this for some time why is it that you
prefer to have a cold home
well i'm cheap uh
it's a little more complicated than that
in that uh
about uh
10 or 11 years ago we put in a
wood stove
and um i believed
the installers who assured me that it
would heat the whole house
knowing what i know now i feel like a
complete mug
it barely heats the sitting room
and and not very well at that uh you
know if you come up against the the fire
it's great but um
the whole point of having a whole house
is to be able to go somewhere else but
one tiny place
um and therefore instead of realizing
that
it was just one more expense in
in a middle-class lifestyle in fact
a wood stove is a luxury item it's not
like being out on the frontier
[Music]
i
decided to go into denial
and pretend that the stove was
sufficient
and so we don't turn on the heating
i i think that my most recent column in
the spectator will convince readers
never to come to my house
maybe that's its intention yeah i have
to say not i have been invited but the
proposition has become a little bit less
and inviting since reading your column
what is the average temperature in your
house then on on any day of the week
well this last winter it averaged about
11.
um but there was a cold snap in january
you may remember i remember it more
keenly than most people
because in our house it got down to
seven
um
and that's the point at which i think it
the atmosphere
qualifies as genuinely uncomfortable
and i have a routine uh during
the winter of
getting up and
you know i i put on thermal underwear
top and bottom um i i'm always wearing a
wall jumper uh and heavy jeans i wear um
knock off ugg boots and a scarf wrapped
double round and a little uh woolen
black cap
and and then i have an entire assortment
of coats they are not just little wraps
they are coats
and uh
my current favorite is a
fake shearling
that has this huge collar that comes up
i look like a nut i look like a nut i um
you know when i go to the door
delivery men
look at me funny
and unless i decide to shiver through a
zoom interview
i look like a lunatic
i most of the time i'm
pretty warm
the
most important thing that i've
been
needed to master
uh in
in just not turning on the heat at all
given what i do for a living is is uh
typing in gloves and this is especially
important because i happen to have
rayno's disease which means that i have
very poor circulation in my hands and
they get cold at
perfectly ordinary temperatures at seven
degrees they're basically they're
falling off my arms
um
and and therefore searching out the
right gloves in which you can type you
know touch type quickly
without the
when they're being warm enough yet not
so fat
that they they touch the wrong keys i
mean i i've got a pair this winter that
was really great they were very toasty
but the
the little finger was
too fat and every time i typed a word it
would turn the caps lock on
it drove me nuts so i had to to wear
thinner ones i mean what this started
out as
an
an eccentricity i um
you know i kind of like the hardiness i
like rising to the challenge of getting
through the winter
uh without turning on the heat
but now
it's
it's practice for the future i mean i i
wrote the column not just to
you know
show off what a
nut i am um but but because
this is this is the way a lot of people
in britain and even in europe more
generally are going to going to have to
start living
perhaps
treating themselves to turning on the
heat when it gets
life-threatening
but
otherwise
resigning themselves that uh
central heating is no longer affordable
it's
it isn't i mean once the price get cap
goes up to close to 3 000 pounds a year
and in the autumn i don't understand how
uh
ordinary britons are going to manage i
mean
taxes are considerable
if you live in a place like london the
cost of your housing is probably through
the roof
and the
uh median
uh
income is something like 27.5
000 pounds i mean where does the money
come from
you know food food costs are
are also escalating fantastically
uh
i don't see
how britons can pay
that energy bill i i it doesn't seem
doable to me not without
you know
not turning on the heat
it it does have this kind of
camping out quality you know you're
suffering adversity i think that's one
of the reasons that it appeals to me
because otherwise i'm completely spoiled
you know i
my wife is not fraught with difficulty
so that i i have to insert it i have to
go looking for it
now as you say i'm sure the chance is
going to come into more pressure we
expect there could be
uh more offered when it comes to the
autumn budget in terms of health for
energy bills but it's not going to deal
with the cost of living crisis people
are still going to be really squeezed um
so before we get on to your tips in
terms of dealing with colder
temperatures in your home i wonder how
does your husband deal with all this is
he on the same page as you has he been
committed to keeping it low
um i think the the short answer is no
and i think that's one of the things i
wanted to warn readers about
is that this can be a source of
considerable marital strife
um my husband is not intuited tall he
puts up with it in the same way he puts
up with a lot of other weird things
about me
but unlike some of the other weird
things about me i do not believe this is
one of the things that he secretly loves
he hates it and he doesn't understand
why this late in our lives we have to
suffer physically
uh he's a professional drummer and and
when it gets really cold he complains
that you know his hands are too cold and
he he can't play his instrument
and i nod
understandingly
but
that doesn't
usually
move me
to switch on the boiler
and i think he's got a point
uh
i think i'm being perverse
and uh i think i i like
i almost like the fact
that energy bills are going up so much
on my own account not on yours um
just because it seems to
justify a policy that i
have instituted
with much more moderate prices if you go
away do you think that there's a chance
he puts the heating on phil whack and
doesn't tell you
you know finally enough he would never
do that
um
i don't know whether that speaks well
for him or not um but
he wouldn't generally take matters into
his own hands
um but i
this is this is one of the things that
we're all going to have to start
managing is these conflicts
people respond very differently to
temperature extremes
some people are much more bothered by it
being too hot than being too cold but
there are others that are very very
bothered
by uh
a cold environment which
you know creates a sense of
of uh
stintiness and um
adversity and it's well it's just it's
not hospitable
it's one of the reasons i have trouble
getting people to come
to dinner in our house i mean
they they arrive and they they know
ahead of time anyone who is still
willing to come to dinner in our house
arrives in these
heavy coats and they wear them all
through dinner
and
i don't blame them i mean i'm wearing
something i'm going to be wearing a a
warm wrap myself
so well that's the other thing is i have
this entire array
of um
of indoor indoor coats for evening
you know they generally um
below the knee sometimes ankle length
and um
you know
just think of the fashion opportunities
so to conclude lionel what are your top
tips for
viewers right now who are realizing that
they're going to have to have the heat
on lower perhaps a lot less in the
coming months
well most of all just get used to
wearing a lot more clothes
and
if you can
encourage yourself to take a strange
pleasure
in denying british gas
their windfall
then do so
a little bit of fu goes a long way in
anyone's life
and it is satisfying to decide you're
not going to be victimized
you're going to adapt
and
it is possible at least in
especially southern england to get
through
most winters
without central heating
and
and i suggest
just give it to go try rising to the
challenge
by the way you're gonna have trouble
with kids they're not gonna like it
thank you lana
that's it for this week once again a
thanks to canaccord generity wealth
management for sponsoring the week in 60
minutes
can accord by the expertise you need to
build your wealth and confidence you can
visit candywealth.com to find out more
and if you enjoyed this episode don't
forget to subscribe to the spectators
youtube channel just click the subscribe
button at the bottom of the video and
tap the bell icon so you never miss an
episode thanks for watching and do join
us again next week
[Music]
foreign